what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Disney is right now currently about
to have their destination
d23 event this is a huge event it's put
on for the fans and it is tied to the
company's 100th anniversary this year
and Disney is calling it the biggest
Disney Fan event of the year and they
promise and I quote here a journey
through every era of Disney as we
venture back through the last century of
Storytelling and look forward to a
limitless future for the company end
quote now Disney's d23 Expo is usually
pretty big in terms of Marvel Studios
however we must clarify that this is a
little bit different this is destination
d23 not the d23 Expo itself however they
do have panels including a Marvel Comics
panel and of course a Walt Disney
Studios panel which of course is
everything from Disney plus to Marvel
Studios lucasfilm Etc and a lot of
people are asking with these panels
coming are we going going to get any big
reveals from Disney for Marvel Studios
could we possibly get some of those
movies that are in phase six that have
not been revealed yet don't worry we'll
break down everything you need to know
about destination d23 and what to expect
from the event in a couple weeks from
now and of course if anything happens
between now and then we'll do an update
video so be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment down below you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items as well
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
so right now there is a lot being said
about destination d23 what to expect
what not to expect it is worth noting
though that this is a pretty big event
since it is tied to the 100th
anniversary of Disney and like I
mentioned they do have a Walt Disney
Studios panel and like I mentioned for
the comic fans they do have a Marvel
Comics panel as well now this event is
going to be taking place September 8th
through September 10th that's Friday
through Saturday this is going to be at
Disney's Contemporary Resort at the Walt
Disney World Resort in Orlando Florida
now they have released a whole schedule
you can find that online but of course
the two things that we care about for
those who care about Marvel comics on
Saturday September 9th the Marvel beyond
Earth's Mightiest celebrating 60 years
of the Avengers panel is going to take
place at about 3 15 to 3 30 p.m so if
you are looking for any Marvel Comics
news be sure to tune in around that time
it's unsure if this is going to be
broadcast yet but if anything new
happens of course it'll be released
online relatively soon after but then on
Sunday what fans really care about is
the Walt Disney Studios showcase and the
description for this reads a sneak peek
an exciting upcoming projects from the
Walt Disney Studios so they've literally
given us sneak peek in the description
for this panel so they are going to show
us some stuff but keep in mind this
isn't just a Marvel panel it's a full
Disney panel so it's a sneak peek at
pretty much all the stuff that they have
coming up from the studio so the big
question is what can we expect from them
now right now the state of the MCU is
kind of in flux because of all of the
writer strikes the actor strikes and
plus not to mention Marvel Studios and
Disney are kind of changing their plans
on how they go about releasing content
this is coming from both Bob Iger the
CEO of Disney right now and Kevin feige
the president of Marvel Studios they
said that they are going to be putting
out less Disney plus content and putting
it out less frequently as well which of
course kind of goes hand in hand anyways
but since the state of the MCU was kind
of in a bit of a flux right now we're
hoping we're going to get some type of
solidified schedule for phase five and
possibly phase six since they are
teasing the future of Walt Disney
Studios and they are describing this
event as a look at the past all the way
to its future we do assume they're going
to talk about some upcoming projects and
I know what everybody's thinking right
now the Fantastic Four are they going to
be talking about the Fantastic Four this
is a project from phase six that has
already been revealed but fans have been
eagerly waiting for the cast as a lot of
people may know we've had a lot of
rumors going around about who could be
the potential cast for The Fantastic
Four we originally heard Adam Driver is
going to be Mr Fantastic his name is
still in there it sounds like Marvel
Studio still wants him but we also heard
Matt Smith could be him as well it was
said that Margot Robbie was locked in as
our Sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman
but now it's said that Vanessa Kirby has
been offered the role of Sue storm and
has accepted it there's also been a lot
of talk about David Diggs being the
thing and Joseph Quinn from stranger
things playing the Human Torch now as
far as we're concerned Vanessa Kirby is
really the only person that has locked
in a role for the Fantastic Four and
that's kind of the problem here we don't
exactly know so we're looking to Disney
and Marvel Studios to kind of shed some
light and tell us what exactly is going
on here Disney could definitely tell us
who the Fantastic Four are at this event
but I'm not sure we are going to get a
full Phase 6 reveal I do however believe
we know when we are going to be getting
that full phase six from reveal we'll
talk about that in a bit but if you are
a Marvel Comics fan or just simply want
to know more about the characters in the
MCU be sure to check out my buddies at
comicbookdirect.com they have created a
website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below so I do think it's a
possibility that Marvel Studios could
reveal the cast of The Fantastic Four or
at least maybe announce that Vanessa
Kirby is Sue storm since that seems to
be the only one that is completely
locked down at this point in time Marvel
and Disney know that we are very eager
for new content pretty much they are
aware that a lot of fans have been
complaining about their recent movies
and shows and they know that we're eager
for more so Marvel and Disney do want to
give us more info to get us more excited
so we will watch their movies and shows
however with the writer strikes and the
actor strikes going on right now
unfortunately a schedule for phase five
and phase six may not be able to be
realistically set I do believe that they
will give us an update for phase five to
the best of their abilities and if they
are going to reveal anything about phase
six they could definitely do it here as
well but like I mentioned I believe that
this is going to happen in another place
and unfortunately we might have a long
time to wait for it right now we are
still kind of towards the first half of
phase five kind of in the middle now but
there is a lot more phase five that we
have left so if Marvel is going to
reveal anything about any schedule or
any surprise projects that are going to
be coming it's probably going to be in
Phase five and while we have hoped that
the strikes are going to end soon and
both parties can come to a fair
agreement it could still go on to last
several more months it could actually go
on to last a year this sucks but it also
does give Marvel Studios and Disney time
to kind of reassess what they are doing
and that includes either adding or
taking away or changing shows in movies
so the basic schedule as it stands right
now at Marvel Studios could completely
change and here's the deal I do believe
that if they do have any solidified
movies and shows planned for phase six
that they know they are going to do yes
they could definitely announce them at
destination d23 if they have fully
committed to whatever projects they're
going to show however I think
unfortunately for the rest of phase six
we're gonna have to wait to the next San
Diego Comic-Con sadly I'm not kidding it
does look like we're gonna have to wait
pretty much a year until we get a full
complete reveal of phase six I do
believe we're going to get revealed part
of phase six either at destination d23
or some other times during the year
Marvel Studios has been known to do kind
of one-off events sometimes where they
reveal some pretty big things plus not
to mention we have investors days and
such things like that but Marvel Studios
didn't attend sdcc this year and that's
always the biggest event of the year so
if you're going to make pretty much the
biggest announcement of the year in the
world of Pop Culture you're probably
going to want to do that at the biggest
event of the year plus like I mentioned
waiting a year really gives them time to
solidify everything they need so while I
do believe we are going to get some
reveals probably some pretty cool ones
at destination d23 I think the big phase
six complete reveal or anything else
like the Fantastic Four cast is probably
going to be held for sdcc simply because
right now with the strikes going on
Marvel Studios doesn't know when they
can continue production with everything
and they don't really know what the full
schedule is going to be like now they
don't know the release dates for all
their projects and since they have so
much time right now they can focus on
improving the quality of the content
that they've already produced and plan
on producing and this could actually
change projects it could change the
direction that they might want to go
with some projects or it could
completely change how they feel about it
altogether and they could just side to
scrap some projects and add new ones
with better characters so sorry for the
fans who heard about this event and were
thinking it's going to be a big full-on
kind of sdcc event or regular d23 Expo
event but just wanted to manage
expectations for this I do think we are
going to get some cool stuff about
Marvel Studios during this event but
sadly I don't think we are going to be
getting the full Phase 6 schedule reveal
during this event but I do think they're
going to show some cool stuff and I do
think it's still going to be exciting
nonetheless so let me know what you
would like to see be revealed at
destination d23 in the comments down
below and how would you feel if we had
to wait an entire year to get phase six
and the cast of The Fantastic Four
revealed to us let me know all your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news of course you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf